[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen meine tochter
heute möchte ich ein ganz neues rezept
ausprobieren
ich habe in der zeitung gesehen dass in
new york hat so ein riesenhype ist und
zwar werden dort in einer bäckerei
kronach zwar kauft vielleicht der
antrieb ist schon aus dem namen machte
sich eine mischung aus kosten- und dome
das heißt sind donuts die eben aus
blätterteig sind frittiert werden
und da ist noch eine vanille füllung
drin sind in apotheken und die werden
mit einer klausur überzogen
also ich denke meine verhältnisse jetzt
vielleicht zu süß welten oder zufällig
so ein krad soll anscheinend 500
kalorien oder so haben keine ahnung
vielleicht hält es sind auch nicht
erwähnen sollen
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall testen
und ich werde dir jetzt aus gekauften
blätterteig machen falls ihr mal
interesse daran habt wie man blättert
eick selbst macht dann würde ich das
diese woche noch für euch machen
in diesem video zeigen sich das
allerdings mit gekauft und blätterteig
weil es einfach schneller geht und ich
einfach mal ausprobieren will ob das
überhaupt was wäre ob mir das schmeckt
oder ob es einfach so süß ist
ich werde jetzt auch meine postings
selber machen ihr könnt aber natürlich
auch ein vanille pudding aus der füße
nehmen
aber das ist nichts anderes als stärke
und etwas farbstoff und wann immer ich
werde das jetzt zunächst etwas geld
machen und einer vanilleschote seinem
und einmalig den frühling machen und
zeigt euch danach eben wie man die
commerz erstellt für den pudding braucht
ihr 250 milliliter milch 35 gramm
puderzucker 20 g speisestärke ein eigelb
und eine halbe vanilleschote die
vanilleschote schneide ich jetzt auf
[Musik]
selbst hier das vanillemark raus mit dem
rücken eines messers
[Musik]
vanille marc gebe ich jetzt gemeinsam
mit meiner mädels in den topf 4 stehen
mit 36 verschwenden und die
vanilleschote schmeißt ihr jetzt nicht
weg ihr könnt die theoretisch auch mit
rein geben und mitkochen
aber ich gebe sie hier in meine
schlüssel mit zucker da habe ich auch
andere vanilleschoten drin und so mache
ich meinen vanillezucker style war die
schoten können da eigentlich jahrelang
drin bleiben und ihr könnt es natürlich
auch für mich sind dann hab da so dieses
dunkle burgau vanillezucker und so könnt
ihr immer wieder zucker nachfüllen und
die vanilleschote geben schon ihr
vanille aroma ab dieses gebe ich den job
mit dem es hier auf dem herd anlass das
aufkochen
in der zeit nehme ich mir schon mal mein
ein und gibt es in eine kleine schüssel
oder eben wir hier einen kleinen topf
ich habe jetzt keine kleine schnitte ist
schade ich es einmal schön aus am besten
hier ist nichts beschlossen keller besen
und da gebe ich jetzt meinen puderzucker
noch mit rein und verrührt ist schön
[Musik]
da noch die stärke mit rein
nebenbei mister gut auf die milch
aufpassen dass ihr euch nicht über kopf
jetzt kocht sie und ich nehme sie kurz
vorm herd runter die zweite ich hier
eine kleine menge wunderbaren mails zu
der alle mitzugeben und das eine und
kann dann die eimasse komplett in dem
milch einrühren herauskratzen
und dann gebe ich das wieder auf dem
herd nicht auf höchster stufe
und das ist noch mal fläche und durch
das ei hat es natürlich die schöne gelbe
farbe ganz ohne farbstoffe und misst das
einmal auch jetzt das reich der
hauptschule dann nehme ich ihn vom herd
runter und jetzt nehme ich mir etwas
frischhaltefolie und steckt den pudding
so einfach dann wieder keiner raus
findet also direkt auf den pudding die
folie andrücken und so kann ich ihnen
jetzt etwas abkühlen lassen
für die krone nehme ich mich ganz normal
in blätterteig gekauften dass ich glaube
dem alten untreue mir den einmal aus und
jetzt müsst ihr denn noch mal in falten
legen also zusammen legen dass wir
einfach mehr schichten hat das heißt ich
gebe mir jetzt erstmal etwas mehl auf
eine arbeitsfläche dass er da jetzt
nicht darauf an klebt
dann lege ich den schönen sorgfältig
übereinander und noch model und wollen
dahin mal darüber dass wir stehen
zusammen geklebt
dass die schicht man eben zusammen
bleiben und das daytona der chrome 8
dann eben nicht auseinander löst und ich
würde sagen ich lege ihnen noch einmal
zusammen dann habe ich ihn insgesamt 123
4 x s zusammengelegt raus und jetzt
nehme ich mir hier kreise zum ausstechen
ich habe hier so die heringe und ich
weiß nicht ob man mit denen ausstechen
kann aber ich denke die kommen von der
stärke her
ich denke die sind so dick wie ein glas
ich probiert es jetzt einfach mal dass
auszustechen
der große kreis hat jetzt einen
durchschnitt von 18 cm
ich habe jetzt nur die befürchtung dass
durch das ausstechen die rentner hier
zusammenkleben und der krone hat da
nicht gut aufgeht und der kleine kreis
durchmesser von vier metern
ich denke es läuft so hinkommen ich habe
auch nie gemacht selber gemacht das
müsste ich auch mal machen aufgeteilt
und jetzt probiere ich mal die zweite
variante das
drumherum schneider mit einem messer ob
das damit besser wird
tietmeyer die einzelnen schichten und da
außen nicht so zusammen
die hat mich halt bisschen sauberer
abschneiden und jetzt hier noch den
kleinen dem dritten steche ich jetzt
noch mal aus dem spiel besser und die
legten kurz zur seite ich habe jetzt
auch schon mal öl aufgesetzt auf dem
herd ich habe nämlich keine fritteuse
und die gebe ich einfach übernehmen und
holger nochmal drüber
und falls die einzelnen schichten nicht
so gut miteinander leben können wir ja
doch etwas brutal rein pinsel etwas
sahne butter
[Musik]
und hier habe ich jetzt schon ein öl
aufgesetzt da ich ein ganz normales
sonnenblumenöl das kann man ja gut zum
frittieren belohnt
ich hab das ding flasche drin es war ein
liter und habe jetzt so auf mittlerer
hitze erhitzen lassen und ihr könnt mit
einem holzlöffel den test machen ihr
steckt in reihen und wenn sich bläschen
um ihn herum bilden zeigt sich mal in
nahaufnahme wenn sich bläschen darum
bilden dann ist es fährt heiß genug und
hier seht ihr dass ich noch nicht so
viel bläschen bilden als ich muss jetzt
da noch ein bisschen warten und jetzt
könnt ihr sehen dass sich das schnell
bläschen um den kochlöffel bilden und so
wie sie eben dass das fett heißt wir
nämlich teigstücke rhein gibt wenn es
halt noch zu kalt ist dann saugen die
viel zu viel fett endlich auf den test
nicht machen wollt könnt ihr auch
einfach ein bisschen dreieck nehmen und
reinschmeißen und daneben dass es auch
bedenken und kann jetzt meinen ersten
tron uprising setzen das mache ich jetzt
hier jetzt so einer schaumkelle einfach
um mir die finger nicht zu verbrennen
schön langsam rein geben und das ganze
solltet ihr zwei minuten etwa auf jeder
seite waffen und gebt auch nicht so
viele in den topf weil sonst das öl
schnell kalt wird und dann einfach die
damals nicht richtig machen können
die krone ich gehe jetzt mal noch das
rein was ich mit hand ausgeschnitten
hatte mit dem messer
[Musik]
und wenn es dann so eine goldbraune
farbe angenommen hat können das umdrehen
das geht ganz gut mit zwei essstäbchen
grad das mittlere loch dürfte ich nicht
so groß machen soll jetzt auch wirklich
aussieht das löschen bisher groß geraten
ich würde mal sagen wenn der äußere
kreis 8 cm sind würde ich den inneren
vielleicht zwei zentimeter ausstechen
reichert hat jetzt gedacht dass es noch
mehr auseinander geht
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt meine heraus und auf
einfach dass das jetzt reicht dem teller
hingelegt mit küchenkrepp und da was ich
das jetzt einfach abtropfen und kann
dann die nächsten zwei backen
ich warte mit den zweiten einfach bis
der erste kurs drin sein so butt ich
jetzt einfach die restlichen aus und
zeigt mich dann wie es weitergeht
als ich habe jetzt hier nochmal aus
einer packung letters tag noch mal
welche ausgestochen und nehme jetzt
diesen deckel als mittleren ausstellte
denn durchmesser von zweieinhalb
zentimeter und die äußeren kreise wie
gesagt 8 cm und so finde ich passt es
ganz gut und ist schön stimmung die
donuts ihnen dann nämlich so aus also da
passt es vom verhältnis her viel besser
und den kleinen brett ähnliche ziele
habe habe ich einfach zusammen geknetet
und form den einfach so zu einer rolle
dann muss er den nicht wegschmeißen und
könnten somit verwerten und könnte sie
dann einfach so verwaschen mini handmade
donau
die kraft lasse ich jetzt hier etwas
abkühlen und für mich in der
zwischenzeit schon mal um die zukunft
uhr
die werde ich aus puderzucker und
zitrone machen also in der zitrone in
klausur und werde dann eben noch den
mann in der pudding in den spritzbeutel
füllen und stand die kaunas neu befüllen
bestreichen und dann mal schauen wie sie
schmecken
für den zitronen zucker kurs nämlich 100
gramm puderzucker und eine zitrone
da werde ich nicht viel zeit brauchen
ich mach mal esslöffel bis 2
schon etwas dickflüssig sein dass er
eben auf den thron sitzen bleibt und
nicht wegläuft ihr könnt ihr jetzt im
prinzip noch einfärben wenn ihr möchtet
ich mache das jetzt einfach mal um euch
das zu zeigen mache ich einfach mal drei
farben könnte man sagen dass ich mach
rosa blau und grün und schnee dazu
irgendeine welten passten farben
[Musik]
um entschieden ich mach rosa blau
immerhin ist die zitrone hast du da
dachte ich nicht gehen und ich fühle das
ganze damit sie es einfach den einweg
schritt folgen
ihr könnt aber auf ganz große geld
fühlten benutzen wenn ihr von einer
einwegspritze hab da einfach eine ecke
so ihnen verschulden und stand da den
zuckerguss rein
so kann man es einfach viel besser auch
spritzen als jetzt mit pinsel sowie
pinsel und dann streiche ich das schön
nach unten gehen die spitze
so macht ihr das dann auch einen
gefrierbeutel und hier mache ich jetzt
einfach noch piloten rein und dann
schneide ich mir gleich die spitze ab
aber eben erst wenn ich sie brauche ein
lebensmittelgeschäft aktiv wird und wir
sehen könnte ich da jetzt keine haut
drauf
natürlich jetzt noch mal schnell durch
und jetzt sollen die krone hat hier noch
geführt werden
ich probiere das ist einmal mit einem
spritzbeutel ich habe da leider nur so
eine kleine loch thüle oder ihnen hat
euch einfach so einwegspritzen die haben
wir vorne auch so ein schönes los
es gibt aber auch fürsprecher expresso
aufsätze mit seinem langen wintern wo
man gut sachen befüllen kann probiert
jetzt einfach mal klappt ja und dann
nehme ich mir hier mal so krohn hat und
sticht da seit ich ein und spritzte
etwas füllung rhein-maas klappt wird
jetzt also vier löcher machen
habt ihr hier so vier öffnungen mit der
füllung drin
und jetzt ist es mal wieder spritze da
habe ich das hier weg gemacht hat es da
reingeführt im löffel und damit kann man
eigentlich leichter einstreichen
dann den super muss ob die corners
spritzen da habe ich aussehen nicht mit
gefilmt die mama und mein papa noch was
ich das für eine farbe doch du kennst
die farbe noch das letzte für die mama
bestimmt toll gemacht jetzt gehts doch
jetzt geht es super und so sehen die
krones jetzt aus also ja die schöne
runde form habe ich jetzt nicht so
hingekriegt das macht jetzt aber nix wie
gesagt mit dem zuckerguss kann man
machen wir mal möchte ich werde ihn
glaube ich er weglassen aber muss
natürlich erst mal probiert werden also
jetzt vielleicht noch ein kurzes fazit
die krone zwar natürlich sehr schnell
gemacht weil ich einfach den fertigen
blätterteig genommen habe ihr könnt
theoretisch auch diesen croissant
teilnehmen allerdings den daher schon
etwas gibt er im kühlregal zu kaufen die
sind so vor bestand in dreiecke aber da
müsstet ihr die ecken eben noch
verbinden miteinander das eben die
dreiecke sich nicht voneinander lösen
und wie jetzt viele bin auch ich
gespannt auf den geschmack und
nachmittags einfach mal eine und
probierte
[Musik]
hatte man vielleicht gehört hat 10 17
mit schön kross im innern sehen sie so
aus also das sieht man auch die fühler
[Musik]
eigentlich nur probier ich muss sagen
die schmecken wirklich richtig gut
ich weiß zwar nicht wie viel kalorien
die haben aber ich auch egal wenn markt
finde ich darf man da gar nicht dran
denken und der zuckerguss muss auf jeden
fall sein
da klingt nämlich schön noch diese säure
und die frische mit in die krone ab
ansonsten wird es denke ich zu süß also
nur dieser blätterteig und ist aber ne
ne pudding aber in kombination mit dem
zitronen bus ist es wirklich ja das ist
wirklich lecker und frisch und auf jeden
fall sollte jetzt mal probieren
nachzumachen ich werde diese woche dann
denke ich noch diesen blätterteig machen
und probiert mal auch direkt mit dem ob
da vielleicht dann besser aufgeht weil
ich finde von der frauen sind zwar ganz
okay also mit im kleineren kreis auf
jeden fall viel schöner und ich zeige
euch das dann entweder direkt in einem
video oder schreib ich eben dazu und ich
wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen
die fünf dollar in america will ich
denke ich vielleicht mal zahlen um es zu
probieren aber ansonsten ist es ja
wirklich sehr schnell selbst gemacht es
kommt eben auf die idee drauf an
dieser mann hatte die idee die weiß
genial und ja auf jeden fall viel spaß
dabei und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
was sich vielleicht noch sagen sollte
holt euch nie wieder typen
vanillepudding dieser selbst gemachte
vanillepudding ist so lecker und so
cremig und ihr habt da einfach keine
farbstoff betreten keine künstlichen
nach oben
die vanilleschote könnt ihr euch
übrigens ganz günstig online bestellen
meine zuschauern im setup die hat mir
dann einen link geschickt ich werde euch
den unten mal in der infobox verlinken
ich habe jetzt noch nicht bestellt sie
hat es anscheinend und schauen was er
zufrieden ich kann ich das bisher auch
noch gar nicht deswegen vielen dank dass
sie mist geschrieben hast und falls ihr
es so shops findet oder regen
irgendwelche läden wo ist das sachen
bekommt schreibt mir auf jeden fall ich
kenne ja auch nicht alles und winter ist
immer bin ich auch tipps bekommen
der papa von lecker schmeckt gut
ok pragmatisch
[Musik]